[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kbhd here and to
wrap up probably my last video for 2012
i want to talk about google now google
now is one of the finest and best and
most revolutionary technologies to be
announced and released in 2012. it's
available on every device running
android 4.1 jelly bean or later and fun
fact when it was being written its code
name and during development was magel
after major barrett who was the voice of
the computer from star trek so it's
pretty badass lieutenant commander data
now located in holodeck area 4j
anyway google now is a step beyond siri
which is ios's personal assistant
because not only does it have superior
voice recognition but it's also a whole
system behind it there's a whole process
and the whole cards ui and everything
about google now behind the scenes that
gives you search results before you even
search for them is amazing so first of
all you can get to google now several
different ways on your device you can
just open it with the google app so you
can tap the google app icon or you can
swipe up on your lock screen or if
you're on a nexus device you can swipe
up from your home screen to open google
now or if you're not running a nexus
device you can assign a swipe action in
your launcher so it really separates
google now from the competitors like
siri or even s-voice for that matter is
the pre-search it's what shows up in the
cards ui before you even search for
anything it presents information that's
relevant to you based on information
that it knows about you google takes
information from your gmail account from
your google searches from your google
calendar all of your google account
stuff and uses that information to
prevent information that's relevant to
you and a lot of people might think that
that's a little weird that you know
google knows all this about you but
you're being tracked by a bunch of
different companies anyway that you
might not even know about so it's nice
that at least google gives you something
back for it and it's free so here are
all the cards that you could possibly
get with all the information google
knows about you from google now the
birthday card for when it knows it's
your birthday the movie theater cards
for when you're near a movie theater the
photo spot card for when you're near a
spot that people like to take pictures
at the public transit card for when
you're near a train or bus station the
places cards for when you're near some
place interesting the translate and
currency cards for when you leave the
country the flight cards for when your
flight is arriving soon the event cards
for when stuff is happening nearby the
sports cards for basketball baseball or
football teams that you've googled the
stock card if there's a big change in
your portfolio the research card which
will help you find more information
about something you've recently googled
the gmail cards which will allow you to
show your boarding pass shipping info or
hotel or restaurant reservations for any
restaurant you've gotten an email for
the activity summary card for those who
walk or bike a lot and the infamous
weather card for whatever city you
happen to be located in and much
much much much more there's a full list
in the description below my personal
favorite one is if your device picks up
that you commute to a place frequently
based on the gps location it'll show a
card in the morning with how long it
takes for you to get to that place and a
notification about 10 minutes or so
before you need to leave to get there on
time based on the traffic in google maps
and provides a onetouch google maps
navigation button to be on your way it's
just genius so aside from all these
cards that will show up based on all the
things it knows about you there's also
voice search and voice search from
google's voice recognition is really
good really fast and very useful i've
done a video about this comparing it to
s voice comparing it to siri a lot of
people are pretty aware by now that it
is really good and really fast and it
knows a lot of information because
google's database of information is so
huge that it's able to get a result back
to you very quickly even if you're not
going to google's database you can still
open apps on your phone and text people
and dial numbers from the google voice
search app what's coming up soon is the
ability to
use os functions so i asked it to turn
off wi-fi and it gave me a message
saying that the system functions are
coming but are not yet implemented
keyword yet also what's neat is you
don't have to use your voice to get a
card with the answer from google so if
you're in a quiet area and you don't
want to talk and look crazy talking to
your phone you can actually type in your
question and if it's in google's
database it'll go ahead and give you a
card with the same answer as if you had
used a voice search so this is what my
google now looks like right now i don't
have a lot of cards but i do use it all
the time almost well pretty much every
day my question to you is how often do
you use google now i know a lot of
people i asked on twitter at mkbhd say
they actually use it a lot more now that
it's becoming more worldwide available
and has more functions added to it my
favorite feature of it by the way is the
package tracker very useful every time i
get an amazon email it just shows up in
google now it's very convenient so there
you go that's my number one favorite
thing that was released in 2012 it's
it's got a long way to go no doubt and
it's it's exciting to see where the
future of google now will go either way
thanks for watching this video if you're
afraid to plus one or give a thumbs up
below that really does help out and if
you want to share this video with you
know new people who got android devices
for the holiday season that's probably
gonna help too so either way thank you
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video
peace
[Music]
you